thing all right welcome to this video
mata leão is still Poland and as you
know i don't recall anything ok Scotch
gambit recall anything I mean for an
earlier games and against them it is an
interesting line that he played him i
recently got into trouble against this
was that against him even that's very
much possible it was some f6 stuff and i
had i got into got into problems it was
a different position though definitely a
different position so f six or what's
what's happening here hmm i should look
at this line it's it seems to me getting
pop more popular somehow maybe night
each form i always disliked it if they
take on 66 this kind of situation i
don't handle well so this is why I just
retreated here okay
go for simple stuff however I think that
this should be a bit better for wide
yeah he's got more space and not a fan
of my position it looks a bit passive he
goes but he have could have 6m the
moment he goes away there i have f6 the
Tiki will take with the night I guess I
wonder if Bishop you for is interesting
and that's an interesting move why not
just try to put it there and go f5 oh no
f5 late-inning said maybe because of a
check here and then e6 the china thing
no idea if this is any good I can go 95
via a B 693 it cannot be all that bad
lexi i take here a b6 ef4 that looks
like full-scale gamble but you can just
recapture some
ok
now probably see five or something that
I pawned could prove to be very strong
no cannot just like take f1 and play be
sure 85 that that's not going to work
it's just just too slow
b6 Queen t6 at least somewhat important
temple now can I do like a look here
something for Quincy five
I only know that works but had to gamble
okay so Bishop to b6 jam second of the
Queen won't work just won't but maybe I
mean in some cases 9526 I think I can
just take or not not be five I cannot
take but this feels less threatening
maybe I mean I'm just I just don't see
how it kills me that sits very much
possible and I'd be five maybe I can
take on the morning but Wow
I didn't have that on the raid idle time
warning okay the night is pinned and I
threatened to take everything and take
you six
five
Quincy six this is no check but it
doesn't have anything spectacular I
don't see it at least I will check here
take you for taking six and check
arya queen no not for nothing fancy
place oh it's okay Zach my plastic ah
come on I mean I can't actually do that
would take back accepted
check check so to draw when I think it's
probably a win because by now he has
weakened at the points that much white
resigns Wow was a tough game and
certainly certainly under much pressure
I have no idea what was going on i think
i have to study that line it did it
keeps popping up and I don't really know
it all that well I mean this isn't
terrible that I still felt like it
should be should be ways to improve on
it and I have six failed logical to me
the moment the night goes back it feels
good and now here this is a good square
you just took it now and this gives me
new squares on d5 and f430 had a direct
idea with this chick and now wait 5 i'm
not sure this is actually a good idea 95
maybe i should just drop back to c7 this
might be I mean he plays this problem
anyway and now the thing is 95 doesn't
look all that tempting
so probably this isn't that great I was
thinking that this could be actually
something like here and here but is it
really doing all that much and takes in
I cannot grab ok so I went back now we
had this and here I felt like I should
be in trouble this tries to bust open
the same time it computer finds a very
strong move that's very difficult for
human player Queen to a three tries to
take with the Queen and I cannot take on
d4 s f8 Hanks we now that's very very
tough and this is also should be good I
mean this here white must be better and
the engine confirms that 1.5 for him ok
this one Andrew kept seven now is strong
yeah taking on Jeff Ward leads to a bad
end that was stronger settle it also is
still good and ok I decided to just grab
it yeah Ruger seven is again strong had
those moves only they're easy for an
engine but form for human it's not not
that easy d 7
check ya as mcteagues so i have to move
this and then you just move the king and
wide wins we got seven still wins and
here i'm kind of back in the game they
are all that pins and after that i'm ok
Kashuk yeah it seems that this is better
very difficult move again for an air for
computer for a human and t i'm holding
according to the engine which is not all
that obvious i mean in a practical game
no idea what happened and here I'm upon
up somehow defend it defended this stuff
with lots of luck ok well thanks for
watching